[Musique]
le
prenez vos séances voulait peaufiner
soit de manière individuelle soit
collective peu m'importe ce qui est
cahier ouvert s'ils ont en main retour à
l'école pour ces 22 stagiaires tous
préparent le même diplôme en brevet
professionnel spécialité activités
gymniques de la force et de la forme
ce jour là enfermé dans cette petite
salle de cours
ils doivent élaborer une séance de
renforcement musculaire fame minutes
d'effort et de récupération en théorie
d'abord puis en pratique
m
tu commences par soit le plus lourd en
premier puis tu enlèves les galettes ou
l'inversé tu gardes ton stock de poids
en bas en sachant que alors ça
franchement c'est pas gênant moi tous
ces stagiaires sont des pratiquants
aguerris des futurs coachs de salles de
sport qui doivent corriger leurs
habitudes souvent basées sur des
sensations plus que sur de vraies
connaissances ici ils reprennent tout à
zéro
ça fait déjà quelques années que je
pratique jette des gens et que je coach
comme ça à titre gracieux des amis pour
avoir une confirmation une légitimité
professionnelle à ses 7 par cette
formation pour être certain que jabiim
personnes je vais faire les bons gestes
et que du coup les gens vont évoluer de
manière saine anatomy biomécanique
méthodes d'animation en emmenant ses
stagiaires vont suivre plus de 460
heures de formation entrecoupé de stages
en milieu professionnel
derrière eux des formateurs du creps qui
s'adaptent à leur profil
c'est remettre un peu d'ordre c'est de
savoir pourquoi on fait les choses
appréhendé aussi un public et pas celui
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'avoir scamandre
et quand on est pratique d'un certain
niveau
bon on pratique avec des gens qui ont un
niveau proche de celui qu'on a et il ya
quand même le coeur du travail dans les
salles de fitness ou les salles de
monsieur ya aussi tous l'apprentissage
donc des gens qui sont débutants des
gens qui sont sédentaires font ça ça
change hausse avec 150 à 200 stagiaires
par an le creps forme à une douzaine de
disciplines du bmx aux sports collectifs
en passant par les activités aquatiques
et nautiques à l'entrée des tests de
sélection révélateur de la qualité de
l'apprentissage dispensés aujourd'hui on
préfère faire une porte in de formation
nous mêmes profs de sport ici au creps
ont délégué bien sûr une partie aux
professionnels du milieu
parce que c'est aussi un gage de qualité
maintenant à la si on veut intervenir
nous mène dans nos formations on doit
limiter
on doit limiter l'offre qu'on a
et pour séduire les stagiaires
l'établissement dispose d'un sérieux
atout en terrain de jeu immense de 21
hectares un lieu de vie parfaitement
adaptée aux besoins de sportifs